six of Wall Street investment firms this
is an hour and five minutes ten shots
I'm professor of political economy here
at the Stanford Graduate School of
Business
this event featuring Greg Smith is
co-sponsored by the Center for Ethics in
society which has a year-long series of
seminars on the ethics of wealth so
there are other parts of that seminar
series that you may find interesting I
think they have a manual siya's coming
in next Thursday or something like that
so this is something that may be of
interest to you going forward throughout
the year before we get started I want to
say a few logistical things actually
first of all Greg is actually doing at
the Stanford bookstore and event at 6:00
p.m. so if you have detailed
conversations you want to have with him
that might be the appropriate forum for
that secondly this actually is being
recorded by c-span so this is for future
broadcast on c-span so just so that you
know if you're asking a question you may
wind up on television doing that and
because of that logistically we have
microphones for Q&A so Greg's going to
talk by for about half an hour and then
he'll do some Q&A so if you have
questions once he gets to QA head to a
microphone and he'll call on you okay in
terms of introducing Greg Smith so Greg
came to Stanford from South Africa in
the late 1990s he graduated from here in
the class of 2001 and immediately went
to work for Goldman Sachs
as you probably know from reading The
New York Times he resigned from Goldman
Sachs last March in a rather
high-profile way that a lot of people
argued about and frankly a lot of people
around the business school on here have
argued about I think you know in some
sense his core point that he was making
was the Goldman used to be sort of a
long-run greedy type of firm in the
sense of trying to build as long-run
profitability by serving client
interests but Greg's argument was that
that had changed something in the
operation of Goldman so that you know
people were more focused on their
personal success of the success of their
subunit or you know profits that they
could make in the short run either via
proprietary trading or commissions or
things like that so this is a topic and
an op-ed
was fairly controversial here in the GSB
I hope that we can have an interesting
dialogue between Greg and you know
people in the audience who probably have
all sorts of different views on this
question so welcome back to Stanford and
we'll look forward to hear what you have
to say thank you very much thank you
very much professor shots can everyone
hear me okay is that a yes yeah okay
it's a it's a great privilege for me to
be back at Stanford like the professor
said the first time I ever came to
America it was actually the day I
arrived at Stanford so I associate
Stanford with a lot of a lot of great
things a lot of idealism a lot of
optimism and it's also great to see a
lot of familiar faces I think they're
three or four people here for my
freshman dorm which which is terrific so
for the students here I was sitting
where you were back 15 years ago
although the business school didn't look
like a hotel back then I it looked a
little bit less fancy but few things
I'll tell you about myself before I
start the one is I am from South Africa
but I have a slightly funny accent
because I lived in California for four
years New York for tenures
London for a year and a half and
originally from jo'burg so when people
ask me where I'm from I often tell them
I'm from Brooklyn just to confuse them
which when they when they get quite
confused and say really I say yeah from
East Brooklyn and that confuses them
even more but I hope everyone can
understand me other thing I would say is
I used to have a ponytail which which is
also hard to imagine and the third fact
about me is I started out at Stanford as
a pre-med which you know I started the
economics track in the pre-med track at
the same time but ultimately I decided
to go into the the business world but
just to get a sense for the audience can
I just take a quick poll who are
undergrads in the audience
and Business School students very nice
and members of the community faculty oh
great okay so we have an excellent and
diverse audience and certainly I'm
looking forward to a good dialogue
because I think people are very split on
a lot of these issues so a couple things
I'll say at the start
professor Schatz mentioned obviously I
wrote this op-ed about goldman sachs but
everything I say today I very much
believe is true to the industry more
broadly you know I don't think Goldman
definitely is a smart firm and an
excellent firm of what it does but I
don't think it's practices are very
different in a lot of ways to the
industry more broadly so you know when I
when I wrote the book and I wrote the
op-ed I was using my career there as as
a prism to the what I think has become
conflicted in the industry more
generally this the second thing I would
say before I start is I think a lot of
people would want to classify my views
or this talk as in the Occupy Wall
Street camp or in you know a different
type of camp what I would say is I'm
very much a capitalist I just have the
view that free markets imply that the
playing field is fair and there aren't
lots of conflicts of interest and a big
thesis of my book and what I was trying
to get across in the op-ed is the fact
that capitalism at least in the
financial industry as it's going on now
I no longer think is on an even playing
field
I think advantages are stacked in favor
of banks and against their investors and
clients in many respects and I think
there's maximum incentive for the system
not to change and I'll get into this a
little bit more later on but let me tell
you the three things I'm going to
discuss today the first is has anything
really changed in the industry certainly
when I wrote the op-ed a lot of people
said well
things have always been this way or Wall
Street has always operated in a certain
sense so I'm going to tell you how at
least since I was sitting where you were
15 years ago in my opinion things have
changed the second thing I'm going to
tell you is with all these changes how
do banks exploit conflicts of interest
to make money in a way that I view as
unfair at best and potentially very
systemically dangerous to society at
worst and the third point will be a
little bit about what needs to change in
order to fix this and why hasn't enough
changed and you know just on that point
I would ask how many people in this room
have heard of the dodd-frank Act how
many people think the dodd-frank Act has
been implemented so so four and a half
years after the crisis and two and a
half years since dodd-frank was passed
less than one-third of dodd-frank has
been implemented and more than
three-quarters of the deadlines have
been missed and four hundred million
dollars has been spent lobbying against
it so I want to touch a little bit at
the end about this perception that
conditions have changed and and really
try to show you guys why they haven't
changed as much as I think Obama or
Romney or any number of politicians
would want people to think so starting
with the the point of what has changed
so I think absolutely they've always
been practices on Wall Street
that are not great and that are dubious
but what I would say the simplest way to
mark what has changed is look how banks
make their money so when I joined the
firm in 2000 or let's just say when I
joined Wall Street at least half the
money was being made in the original
things that made finance get called
finance Wall Street financed things that
helped companies raise money they
advised companies on merging they acted
as an advisor in all sorts of capacities
so when I joined about 60% of gold
sexist revenue was in the banking side
of the business where certainly there
are always going to be conflicts but
there are less conflicts than in the
trading side of the business so fast
forward to 2007 close to 80% of the
money is being made in the trading
business which you know is a very marked
change which I don't think people can
debate as being a you know non factual
but what that kind of revenue change
does is it leads to behavioral changes
and cultural changes so what occurred
that allowed this revenue shift to
change three main things occurred right
around the time when I was joining Wall
Street the first thing in 1999 there was
a thing called the glass-steagall Act
which separated commercial banks from
investment banks it was repealed in 2000
there was a thing called the Commodity
Futures Modernization Act which
essentially took complex securities
called derivatives and deregulated them
so allowed the trading of derivatives to
move off exchanges basically into the
dock and the third thing that happened
was a thing called the net capital rule
was overturned and what that did is it
allowed banks to increase their leverage
from now leverage for those who don't
know is basically if you have $1 you can
effectively lever yourself up by taking
bets 10 or 20 or 30 times the amount
with the $1 you have by borrowing extra
money so from the early 2000s to the
mid-2000s banks took their leverage from
you know five six seven to one up to
thirty five to one so with these three
things which were all regulatory in
nature and which were all ultimately
lobbied for by the banking industry it
became very clear that as a professor
said the old model of long-term greedy
which their long-term greedy was a
modder that Goldman Sachs had for many
years which essentially said
we do right by clients over the long
term and maybe we turn away business in
the short term that's going to affect
our reputation ultimately they'll keep
coming back to us and we'll have a
collaborative relationship with a client
as a partner and they keep paying us and
they keep doing business with us because
they trust us this shifted to a model
that I would call short-term greedy
which ultimately makes more profits for
individuals and for the firm in the very
short term but from a long-run
standpoint doesn't serve your business
well and doesn't serve the society well
because potentially you're doing
business has toxic to your clients and
ultimately in dangers the system as we
saw in 2008 where Lehman Merrill Lynch
AIG had taken such huge risk that it
ultimately brought the whole system down
in the government had to come in and
bail the system out so when we talk
about all these regulations occurring
what basically happens is it becomes
clear that it's more advantageous for
the bank to start betting with their own
money because if you can take levered
bets of 30 to 1 you may actually start
seeing your client more as an
information provider to help you bet
more smartly as opposed to seeing your
client as a partner that you help make
returns and earn money and essentially
in the early to mid part of my career I
saw this cultural shift occur where the
firm started seeing what the biggest
mutual funds and pension funds in the
world were doing and started
implementing its own bets using this
information in a way that was not
front-running technically but allowed
banks to use this big picture kind of
sitting in the middle position to bet
and you know you can look at the the
evidence goldman sachs is trading
revenues for example in 2002 were 5
billion dollars by 2007 it was 38
billion dollars and you know businesses
don't multiply by five or six times in
five or six years unless there is some
meaningful shift in your mindset
so ultimately that leads to a what I
call a behavioral or cultural shift and
you know this doesn't happen overnight
but if people are being incentivized to
use their client information or to bet
with the firm's own money and no one is
telling them that there's anything wrong
with that
it ultimately filters up and down an
organization and this cultural shift
occurred everywhere on Wall Street
during that period looking you know just
a few examples too to show this this
mindset shift just in the last year or
so I mean you can count down the what
I'd call scandals that show this type of
swing for the fences behavior you know
you had MF Global which was a futures
brokerage in Chicago where the head of
the firm started taking proprietary bets
on the sovereign crisis in Europe and
ultimately the firm went bankrupt
there was a scandalous situation where
there were potentially using customer
money to fund these bad bets and no one
no one has been prosecuted for that
secondly in the last few months we've
all heard about the LIBOR rigging
scandal LIBOR is an interest rate that
affects hundreds of trillions of dollars
of assets around the world and this is
this is I would say a an example of this
incentive where traders were
collaborating with each other to set an
interest rate because they knew they'd
make more money for the firm you look at
the Facebook IPO there we can argue
endlessly was a Facebook's fault was it
Morgan Stanley's fault was it the
investors fault but certainly a
manifestation of this you know let's
swing for the fences try to get as much
out of this deal as possible so let me
let me go into point two which is a
little bit trying to explain how banks
use make this money using a little bit
of analogy which I use in my book if you
think if you compare Wall Street today
which seventy five percent of revenues
come from trading to a real casino so
not it not everyone likes gambling but
whether we like gambling or don't like
gambling
when you walk into a casino you can have
a lot of faith that the rules are not
going to change during the game and that
there are cameras all over the floor and
that there is a regulatory body that for
the most part is keeping an eye on
things the other thing I would say is
the casino or the house is not allowed
to take bets based on what everyone in
the casino is doing the casino is a what
I'd call an objective counterparty so
let's let's just run through this
analogy a little bit if you think about
an investment bank they are dealing
everyone cards and let's say at the
table is sitting a pension fund a hedge
fund a mutual fund you know hundreds of
billions of dollars of investors are
sitting at this table that bank or the
dealer can see what all those people are
doing and can then go out and use it
information to place their own bets now
you would expect someone not to lose
very often if you can see everyone's
cards and this is very much borne out in
an example we see every quarter where
banks have to release their results on
their trading books for the whole
quarter
there are many quarters where a bank
will literally make a profit 100% of the
time so that that's like batting a
thousand where you know if you go to the
plate you would not expect someone to
hit every time so you got to think to
yourself I'm sure most people in this
room invest in the market if you make
money fifty point one percent of the
time you're probably outperforming many
many people in the market it's very hard
to understand how a trading book can
make money 100 percent of the time
unless you have some kind of asymmetric
information advantage and and that is
you know where I would come back to the
analogy of you're essentially seeing
what everyone else is doing so you can
bet a lot smarter with your own money
second part of the analogy when I
mentioned the cameras what happened with
the deregulation of derivatives is the
gambling can be taken to a backroom
where there are no cameras and no one is
trekking who is losing a lot of money
and who is making a lot of money and
this is the example of Lehman Brothers
and best
and Merrill Lynch who no one knew how
much risk they had on their books and it
turned out that they had all sorts of
risks that no one in the market knew or
understood and this is the big danger of
business being done in an opaque fashion
in the dark in a very complex nature so
I would argue ultimately you need to
bring the gambling out of the dark room
and bring it back into the light or in
exchange where everyone can see what's
going on to continue a little bit with
the analogy and this is what I think is
the most dangerous part of the way
business is done in Wall Street today
it's the dealer now when you're playing
blackjack I think everyone knows the
rules you know you can't if you get more
than 21
you bust you know there are certain
statistical probabilities you should and
shouldn't be betting on when you go to
casino does anyone in the audience
expect the dealer to give them bad
information for example a big boy
attitude where the dealer is actually
telling you when you're on 19 that you
should be taking other card I think no
one no one would expect you know when at
least when I have been to casinos the
dealer is actually kind of on your side
and somewhat friendly and will tell you
you know because you often do see people
who have never gambled before who will
take another card in 19 and ruin
everyone else's hands but the dealer
would likely tell you this is a bad idea
you shouldn't be doing it so I think you
have this what I would call an implicit
sense of trust where you don't expect
the dealer to misguide you what
sometimes happens on Wall Street is a
client or investor will get told to do
something that if they understood the
rules of the road very well they would
know is not in their interest to do yet
a Wall Street firm will tell them you
should do this because their firm might
make ten or fifteen or twenty million
dollars of it and they're not
technically doing anything illegal
because that person walked into the
casino they
you are responsible for their own
actions and I think this is where a big
misunderstanding comes in and you know
I'm sure many of you remember in 2010
there was a big SEC lawsuit against
Goldman Sachs and there was a big
hearing in front of Carl Levin where a
lot of swear words we used some TV the
one particular word beginning with an
Shi tty was used I think 20 times
because of how Bank has spoke about
these deals you know the big argument
for why it was okay to sell someone
something without full disclosure or
without fully telling them your
intentions was this idea that they're a
big boy and everyone's a big boy if
they've if they've come to play they
deserve what's coming to them even if
there is a sense of deception or a sense
of misleading them now I think a lot
about the word fiduciary duty and you
know this is a word that I think is
thrown around a lot but the central
meaning of it is when someone is coming
to you for advice if you are bound by a
fiduciary obligation you owe that client
or that person the duty of telling them
what is in their interest and what is
not in their interest and I think over
the time I was in Wall Street there has
it is morphed into the sense that a
fiduciary duty is not owed to anyone the
big problem with that is I would argue
many many clients with hundreds of
billions of dollars of assets don't
understand it and you know an example
I'll give you two examples that
ultimately led to me writing the op-ed
and and you know I'd like all of you to
think about just as an ethical dilemma
especially since we live in a time today
where the idea of ethics versus legal
are very different things if something
is technically legal and it's not going
to get you sent to jail a lot of people
will do those things so the example I
would give you to think about is that we
recently had a terrible storm hurricane
sandy everyone gives donation
to say the Red Cross Society or any
other number of charities I think what
the general public doesn't always know
is Red Cross every University down meant
Stanford Harvard teachers pension funds
police pension funds fireman's pension
funds governments are the biggest fish
in the market they have hundreds of
billions of dollars of assets and they
invest them to walk with Wall Street so
what I would ask is just as a
hypothetical example if the Red Cross
Society came to you and asked to trade a
very complicated derivative product that
was going to pay the firm 20 million
dollars yet you knew was not in their
interest but was not necessarily going
to get you sent to jail because the
government classifies them as
sophisticated would you do that business
and more and more I saw the the attitude
and the behavior move to a point where
yes we will do that business because
they're a big boy now I would argue it's
reached a point where because of the
asymmetric information advantage I've
told you about not everyone's on an even
playing field so more needs to be done
to prevent that kind of behavior the
second example I would give you which is
a very powerful one in making helping me
make my decision to leave was the
European sovereign crisis which you know
is still boiling but we may remember
last summer the summer of 2011 it looked
like Portugal Spain Italy we're
teetering on bankruptcy and I would go
to training meetings every morning and
our traders would have a very negative
view on the European banks yet we were
being asked to go to some of the biggest
investors in the world and try to
convince them why the European banks was
such an attractive investment purely
because we didn't like the investment
and wanted to sell the banks but we
needed someone on the other side of the
trade to buy the banks now if we were
just talking about some arcane
investment that didn't affect anyone
this might not be so relevant but I
would go to my desk and I would see the
biggest banks in France and
I mean you're moving up and down in 5-2
temps in a day not purely but largely
driven by this idea that every two days
in order to drum up business clients at
all banks across Wall Street were being
convinced today is a day to sell
tomorrow you should buy now is the time
to panic and the truth is our traders
and traders across Wall Street didn't
really believe that conditions were
changing on the ground every day and to
me this started having real real-world
impact you know there are millions of
citizens across Europe who are affected
by the fact that their governments can't
get their act together and banks are
trying to drum up business
in order to make their profits at the
end of the quarter and and this
ultimately you know became something
that I thought crossed the line of you
know a letter of the law goes a spirit
of the law and ethical versus legal and
I think it got to a point where I felt
this wasn't the type of business that I
wanted to do anymore
the final point I'll talk about before I
take some questions and answers will be
what needs to change in order to fix the
system in my opinion the one thing I
would say which I don't think a lot of
people know necessarily is that the five
biggest banks in America are now bigger
than there were before the financial
crisis whatever people claim or don't
claim banks still have an implicit and I
would almost argue explicit guarantee
that whatever they do the government
will support them now
just to explain this perverse incentive
a little bit there was an example last
summer where a JPMorgan trader who was
nicknamed that I think the giant whale
or the London whale basically took a
massive bet lost six billion dollars for
the firm got a wrist slap lost his job
the person who ran that group I think
over the course of her career maybe made
more than 50 million dollars and left
the job now if that loss had been 200
billion
instead of six billion dollars the thing
that happened to the person who took
that trade would be exactly the same
they would get a wrist slap they would
leave their bank and all of society
would have to bail out that bank because
of this existing implicit and explicit
guarantee that we saw you know anyone
who talks about cut through a free
market capitalism we saw in 2008 when
faced with this idea of are you really
going to let the banks fail the truth is
a government wasn't willing to take that
risk and wasn't willing to see what
happened and everyone a wall street
knows that and there's now this maximum
sentence wing for the fences do whatever
you can to maximize profits because the
trade goes bad you're just going to lose
your job but if the trade goes bad for
society everyone has to bail banks out
and I think what this amounts to today
is what I call a privatization of the
profits and a socialization of the
downside risks and that is absolutely
still enforced today anyone who claims
that is not in force is not in my mind
telling the truth now why is not enough
done to fix this I would you know at the
very end of my book I point the finger
back at politicians and the truth is I
think the thing we should all be most
outraged about is the fact that look at
the Senate Banking Committee who are the
firms that are giving them the greatest
campaign contributions
it's the Goldman Sachs JP Morgan Morgan
Stanley's of the world look at the
regulators look at the hundreds of
millions of dollars that have been
lobbied in order to kill regulation and
this was very counterintuitive to me but
the way to kill legislation in today's
day and age is not to get rid of it or
to get it struck from the act it's to
fatten it up and this wasn't obvious to
me at first but there's a thing called
the Volcker Rule which is designed to
completely eliminate proprietary trading
which is banks betting with their own
money it started out as a two-page
document written by senators Merkley and
Levin as an amendment to dodd-frank to
later it's something like 700 pages
because banks realized if they can get
their law firms to insert hundreds of
loopholes and amendments you ultimately
reach a point where the law is so
complicated that no one can actually
follow it and essentially you've
achieved this victory where nothing has
changed at the end of the day so I think
we need to say to politicians you know
number one why don't you have the
political will or the guts to actually
fix a problem that affects everyone
banks can still be profitable they can
still do the things that serve society
or serve I would say economic prosperity
which is raising money helping companies
merge but when 80% of banks profits are
coming from trading I don't think banks
or politicians are being honest with the
public with how their money is being
made and you look at commercials on TV
for Citigroup
or Goldman Sachs or JP Morgan you would
think they're in the business of helping
New Orleans rebuild or about giving
money to charities and certainly there
is a significant amount of philanthropy
on Wall Street but I would say to you
the amount of money that's made by
helping New Orleans rebuild or investing
in urban communities is less than 10
percent I think there needs to be a
greater sense of honesty where people
actually are upfront and say look 80
percent of the money is being made in a
business that the public doesn't
understand frankly politicians don't
fully understand and I would say to you
regulators are not I would say resourced
enough or nimble enough to understand
things because they're so complex so
what I'm advocating for is a return to
the old long-term model where you do
business you make money
your clients make returns banks can
still be profitable
and people who do things at risk I would
say the systemic safety of the economy
are held accountable and the way to do
that and I'm not a huge fan of
regulations but I think the three big
things you need to do the one is
derivatives you need to bring them back
into the light you need to bring them
onto exchanges
proprietary trading through the Volker
rule you need to outlaw it and the law
does not have to be 700 pages the law
can be one page now a lot of times banks
will hide behind the idea of market
making or hedging which is more
complicated discussion but I would tell
you is a way to hide behind something
that still lets you continue to do
proprietary trading and then the third
one which I'm interested to hear what
people in the audience think is about
our banks too-big-to-fail still and are
they too big and too complex to manage I
would say they definitely are and I
would say there's a critical mass
building where you don't to be
destructive to banks but when they're
still so systemically dangerous is there
merit to making them smaller where you
split off the trading business from the
retail side of the business and I would
argue yes there is merit to that so with
those three things I'll leave it there
and thanks for listening and I'll open
it up for questions
first come first serve as that let's go
ahead thank you
Greg thank you for speaking it seemed
like a lot about what you're talking
about was sort of a policy analysis of
what the situation is on Wall Street
today but I think a lot of us in the
audience are interested even taking
those issues as a given the way you've
described it from a personal perspective
if we were in your shoes what is our
duty and what is the best way to affect
change so what one thing that I noticed
was in the years since you first did the
op-ed and you attracted a massive amount
of media attention a lot of that
momentum seems to have died down over
time there doesn't seem to be the same
degree of scrutiny or over Goldman over
Wall Street generally and it made me
wonder maybe part of it is because by
publicly publicizing your reason for
leaving goldman sachs even potentially
sympathetic employees at goldman faced
some sort of pressure to defend the
integrity of the firm because they were
being attacked from the outside and
perhaps you faced more resistance than
you would have had you taken this
eternally so i'm wondering given the
information you know today if you had to
do it all over again would you think it
would have made more sense to have sent
the same content of your op-ed but not
sending it to the New York Times but
emailing it to every employee in the
goldman sachs worldwide directory i
think i think that's a great question
and and there is a way to send something
to everyone in the in the global
directory which everyone fantasized
about at some point if you mistakenly
sent an email to everyone but no i think
what i would say to you is is it took me
I talked about in the book I wrote the
op-ed over four months as I went through
a process of having dozens of
conversations first were the people
sitting around me and quietly behind
closed doors a lot of people on Wall
Street feel a sense of angst about the
sense that the game could end
any day and I think you know there every
one I'd say 95% of Wall Street are
fundamentally decent people but I think
they're being asked to do things that as
I've been talking about step over the
line of what I think is ethical at times
and what I would say to you is I don't
think Goldman Sachs is the problem I
think this is a systemic problem and
it's the reason I know the professor was
saying Preet Bharara is going to be here
next week and I think there's a real
temptation in the public to think that
if we send two or three bad eggs to jail
the problem is going to be fixed the
point I try to get across my book is
this is not a problem about a few bad
people making bad ethical decisions this
is about a whole system that doesn't
just discourage people to make these
decisions
it's incentivizes people to make them
because their bonus is going to be
directly determined by how much they
bring in so after I had conversations to
almost head check myself with people
that they felt a similar way I also had
conversations with nine different
government partners behind closed doors
half of whom agreed with me about these
ethical lapses and longed for a time
where you did return to this long-term
greedy mentality but it gets to the
point where there's a thing called the
golden goose and as long as it is paying
people a lot of money there's not a lot
of incentive to pull the curtain back
and to actually change the system and
you know what I would say to you is
there are a lot of people who are in
difficult situations you know not
difficult relative to the world but you
know they're people who have sent their
kids are going to private school you
know they have all sorts of bills
they're living an expensive life and you
know by by sending a letter to people
internally I could very quickly see
through my conversations with people
including a couple people on the Goldman
Sachs Management Committee and by the
way this I think applies to any firm
there's not a lot of incentive to change
something if you're doing something and
you're not going to jail for it and
you're not getting into trouble for it
in my opinion by talking to people about
it internally you were not going to have
an
act because I think this problem is as
big as politicians and regulators not
understanding the broader problem so
ultimately you know I decided I was
going to leave but I did think there'd
be merit in trying to say something
publicly in order to not destroy the
profitability on Wall Street but maybe
return it to a more sustainable fashion
and I'll just give you an example for
the business school students here you
look at is the short-term greeting
that's actually good for Goldman Sachs's
business or JP Morgan's business and I
would say to you I don't think it's good
for the business either and look at how
the stock market values banking stocks
banking stocks are valued at the low
liquidation value which tells you that
even the market doesn't like this model
where there's no predictability
there's no sustainability there's no
long-term orientation look at JP
Morgan's earnings statement there is
ZERO disclosure of how the money is made
and where it's being made from and
investors can't value companies
correctly so you know I just thought
there'd be something to be said for
saying something publicly because I
think if the people from within the
industry don't say something I think
nothing is going to change and I think
we're going to go through the cycle
where every seven or eight years we have
bubbles that expand and ultimately burst
and let's hope that doesn't happen again
that's pretty discouraging isn't it Greg
you bring out a really good point that
says the process of regulation seems to
be kind of hopeless in other words the
the big moneyed interests are going to
be able to defeat it over time by boring
from within or as the old Romans used to
say you know who watches the Watchers so
it seems to me do you have an ethical
thing we have to have to change the
structure now looking back historically
do you see how do you see the the move
from having these great investment
houses move from a partnership to a
corporation and then do you see a
correlation of that the the emphasis
being on a fiduciary relationship versus
a counterparty relationship do you see
that historically or not I see it as
being
huge contributor to the problem and you
know goldman sachs was the last large
private firm on Wall Street and when you
are a private partnership your partner's
incentives by definition are much more
aligned with your clients if you do a
deal with the government of Libya and it
ruins your reputation and people start
pulling their money from your firm you
as a partner are going to feel immediate
pain because your capital is tied up
when these firms became public it became
much harder to really take ownership of
the problem and I do think that is an
issue I think it's hard to go back in
time and privatized firms but when they
were private incentives were aligned and
I think clients interests were better
served and banks were less dangerous
because they were less big the reason
banks became public was because of this
move in the late 90s by Sandy Weill and
others to create these what I call
banking supermarkets like a Citigroup
where in order to compete every
investment bank had to get bigger by
getting public funding and you know if
we could go back in time and I think
reverse glass-steagall being repealed
reverse de river derivatives being
deregulated reverse the leverage issues
you know in my opinion I don't think we
would have had this scandal as bad I
mean the financial crisis could have
still occurred but I don't think it
would have occurred on the same scale so
ultimately I think the way you fix it
now is you point the finger at
politicians and regulators and you say
to them we elected you to understand
what is going on if the system is too
complex to understand you need to make
that system less complex if you are
being corrupted or unable to be
objective because people are giving you
money and lobbying and funding your
campaigns the electorate needs to vote
those people out of office and say you
know what this senator is no longer
objective this regulator running the SEC
no longer understands what's going on
and I'm just you know upset the public
isn't more tuned in to this issue and my
biggest goal in the way and the book was
really to write this book not for a Wall
Street audience or anyone to know
anything about finance but I would say
to write it for people who know nothing
about finance to pull the curtain back
to cents to show there are a lot of good
things are gone on Wall Street but there
are a lot of conflicts of interest and
only if the public holds politicians
feet to the fire will things change so
my hope is that and really a question
was you know how can business school
students and college students change
things the one is speak to your
politicians hold them accountable fools
fill yourself in on the issues and when
you do go work in finance act within
your own ethical compass and you know
one by one I think people can change
things but I do think politicians
ultimately probably hard with the
largest amount of blame in this problem
hi Greg this is a great segue to my next
question what are your plans in the
future as far as your career I think
you'd be great in Congress or working
for the SEC or the Department of Justice
with your background and values and I'm
sure there's people in this room who
would support you oh thank you well I've
told some people I'm becoming a DJ which
is not a very very popular thing just
just as a joke but no I mean in the in
the short term my plan is to try to
bring awareness to I'd say the the most
short term crisis which is the fact that
dodd-frank is dying what I call a very
slow death by a thousand cuts
and you know I'm sure everyone tuned in
to the presidential election not one
candidate talks about financial reform
doesn't matter if you're a Democrat or
Republican there's literally I would say
one person running for Senate who even
mentioned it was Elizabeth Warren who
you know we can agree or disagree about
the I would say whether her views are
accurate or not but what I do commend
her for is that she is talking about it
which I think it would affect people's
lives politicians should talk about it
so I want to be part through giving
talks like this to bring a little bit of
awareness to what I view as a serious
problem and then longer term I would
like to be helpful to Congress I would
like to be helpful to the SEC I have
been I've been in touch with with people
in Congress and I hope to be helpful to
them
and in terms of my longer-term plans I I
haven't figured it out yet I think a lot
of people said well you burnt your
bridges on Wall Street you're never
going to work there again but I think
the point I make to people is like
that's not what I'm hearing from the
public in terms of this idea of
returning to a fiduciary standard
because as I said the big players in the
market are not hedge funds hedge funds
are rich investors account for less than
5% of the markets the big players are
teachers pension funds and sovereign
wealth funds and mutual funds who hold
people's 401ks and donations and
retirement savings so I do think
ultimately I would like to be part of
the solution in terms of bringing a
greater fiduciary standard back to
markets I'm sorry yeah earlier in your
talk you mentioned Merrill Lynch and
Lehman Brothers and Bear Stearns as
being three firms that were what over
leveraged and operating in the dark and
they kind of disappeared could you could
you give us your thoughts on why Lehman
was allowed to kind of burn up and the
other two were so-called rescued it's a
it's a very current very controversial
topic which I think conspiracy theorists
will talk about for a long time but I
think you know I was I was sitting on
the trading floor at the time that
happened and you know at when Lehman
Brothers was allowed to fail you know
any of any record checkers or fact
checkers should go back and look at the
editorials the following day both
liberal periodicals and conservative
periodicals praised Hank Paulson for
drawing a line in the sand and saying
you know what like if you take
irresponsible risk and your leaders
aren't willing to you know fix the
problem we'll show the right amount of
transparency you are going to be allowed
to die and ultimately when the
government reverse course on AIG and on
multiple other things I think it just
showed a tremendous amount of
uncertainty to the markets and everyone
panicked and they led to more problems
so looking back on that I I think it was
a mismanagement in that what markets
like and anyone invests in stocks will
know markets like consistency they like
to have foreseeability into what's going
to happen in the future and the fact
that every day was a guessing game of
who is going to be allowed to live and
who was going to be allowed to die it
was a very dangerous thing so I think
perhaps everyone should have been saved
or everyone should have been allowed to
die and I you know I think everyone
would have been scared to see what
happened but and it's an extreme view
but ultimately I think history will look
back on it and you know the crisis
probably would have been worse if Lehman
or its I'd say it's very hard to say and
I would say you need a crystal ball in
order to tell that's uh first of all
thank you for speaking out I think on
Wall Street a lot of paychecks are
dependent on not speaking out so I
wanted to thank you for that there is
precedent for prosecuting people for
securities fraud like in the 1980s
during the kings Savings and Loan
scandal just wanted your thoughts about
how or why there have been zero criminal
prosecutions of any Wall Street
executives yeah it's a it's an excellent
question and and I think a question
everyone in America asks and I'll tell
you the reason is quite simple it's that
the laws are not I would say on the
level that allows criminal prosecutions
to take place very easily and this is
what Wall Street wants right now you
need to prove criminal intent to defraud
people and now you look at any number
number of examples you look at the MF
Global example which is a particularly
egregious one where Jon Corzine who was
the former head of Goldman and ended up
being a senator and a Governor of New
Jersey essentially a billion dollars of
money just disappeared and the reason or
at least the reason Congress will tell
the public that no one goes to jail even
gets prosecuted is because in order to
prove intent that they were trying to
defraud people is a very hard thing to
do so what I would argue and and as I've
said I'm not I'm not I wouldn't classify
myself as a pro
regulation person but I think any
thinking person realizes that if you're
if everyone is driving race cause and
there are zero speed limits and everyone
is just mandated to self-regulate and to
not crash into people ultimately you're
going to get bad actors that crash into
other people so I think I think the laws
need to change and the laws need to be
more strict and you know the hope was
the momentum come out of the crisis
would be used to change those laws but
unfortunately we're we're kind of four
years in the distance things are fading
into memory and frankly that's what
banks want they want this to recede into
memory you know personally I thought the
JP Morgan example was was something that
should have been a much bigger deal
because it was very symptomatic of this
reckless we gamble and if we win we keep
the profits if we lose we don't have to
worry about it I think it was an
opportunity for Congress to change
things and you know Preet Bharara will
be at the Business School next week has
done some great work prosecuting insider
trading which frankly right now is what
I call the low-hanging fruit because
it's easy to prove a billionaire used
misinformation in order to make some
money for himself or herself the truth
is insider trading doesn't actually
affect that many people the real issue
in my mind that that the Justice
Department and lawmakers should be going
after is this systemic issue of you know
I mentioned earlier this idea of
proprietary trading no longer goes on
what I would tell you is it's absolutely
going on it's just going on under what I
call a new term which is hedging or
market making we're doing this in
service of clients the truth is in my
mind and in my opinion much less is
being done in service of clients much
more is being done by using the fact
you're serving clients in order to make
yourself smarter to place your own bets
and I just think Congress needs to
become a lot smarter and fixing that
rule and if they can fix that rule I
actually think it would be more valuable
than sending two or three people to jail
because a great danger of that is then
everyone says well we've not fixed the
problem the real problem is much greater
than that is much more systemic too
mind yes you mentioned that mutual funds
are among the major players in the
market um do these systemic factors that
you've mentioned have a significant
impact I will call mainstream mutual
funds you know that invest in equities
or fixed income as opposed to some of
the fringe players and should we as
individual investors have any concerns
in that area I absolutely and I'll give
you a couple examples sure people
remember in May 2010 there was a thing
called the flash crash where the market
literally dropped something like 12% in
one second and no one could explain what
happened and you know I think people who
had researched the issue speak about a
thing called high-frequency trading
which Wall Street firms have computers
that they get to the stock a millisecond
before anyone else and this causes a lot
of volatility so I would argue mutual
funds no matter how vanilla they are
they're still investing your money in
stocks and if the market can't be
assumed to be fair and without uneven
advantages I do think people should be
concerned and I do think your mutual
funds should also be held accountable
not to use complex products like
derivatives when they don't fully
understand them because a lot of the
time they don't thank you thank you very
much I have a question that's related to
some of the answers that you've provided
you've in I think all of your responses
you've talked about regulations that are
instituted and enforced and then you've
also talked about incentives and perhaps
disincentives for some of the behavior
that exists I'd like to understand given
the complexity of enforcing regulations
and and the process that you've advised
the audience here than the new grads and
and the future generation of finances in
Wall Street what would you recommend on
the disincentive side aside from the
sort of the legal consequences of
violating the regulation something that
that actually relates to the financial
rewards and and then in that context if
you could also
- tell us what differentiates what goes
on here in the US vs. did versus the
European market
a good question I think a lot of lot has
been raised about compensation on Wall
Street and I think you know one of the
ways a Wall Street firm will defend
paying people 10 or 20 or 30 million
dollars is that well if we don't do it
they'll just go somewhere else and
they'll do it and I think this is a
circular thing that keeps going on round
around and around and I think if firms
decided to bring incentives back in line
things would change I think the way you
do that is you have to tie compensation
and incentives to performance of your
clients and you have to tie it to a
long-run orientation where you take away
the incentive like the London whale had
to swing for the fences because they
wanted a big bonus in year one you have
to make compensation based on a five or
ten year track record where claw backs
are very strict they're actually enacted
you know yesterday I'm sure many people
saw at you know Jamie Dimon who was a
CEO of JPMorgan his compensation was cut
because of because of the London whale
incident and people might say well
that's a great victory what I would say
is it to me it's more of a band-aid it's
trying to show the public we're doing
something there needs to be a more
systemic change in incentives but the
truth is that human nature and greed is
something we as a people in my mind
cannot regulate and and I think you know
if one had to fault some of the protests
that took place around Wall Street you
know what I think is effective is
protest something very simple and
factual like bring derivatives onto
exchanges outlaw proprietary trading so
don't give people the ability to swing
for the fences because you take away the
products are using to do that I think to
try to tell people you need to make less
money or you know we're going to cap
your pay at X amount or Y amount doesn't
I don't think jives with American
capitalism as I see it I think people
should be at
to get rich and should be able to make
lots of money I just think they should
be required to do it in a transparent
way that doesn't endanger other people
and I think the easiest solution in my
mind is hold regulators accountable hold
politicians accountable and take away
the things that allow people to swing
for the fences by regulating the markets
more smartly I would say in terms of the
question about Europe versus the US
Europe I would say is is more like the
Wild West than in the US and the last
chapter of my book when I moved to
London I actually called the chapter the
Wild West because there's very much a
greater sense of anything-goes but I
would say the u.s. is a leader in a lot
of these products and Europe tends to
follow so if the US can get these laws
right you know the reason I think banks
don't want Congress to pass these laws
is I say well if we do it here banks
will move to Europe I guarantee you if
the u.s. changes something makes a
system more responsible there is going
to be a sense of awe betras around the
world where everyone's trying to get
somewhere else but ultimately the u.s.
is the biggest strongest market in the
world and I think others would follow if
we did things a bit better here we next
oh go ahead Greg in terms of your your
second point of the asymmetric nature of
information and the casino analogy when
we talk about deposit creation like this
going on right now like that
the last month of last year there was
220 billion of deposit creation in the
US system that's working its way into
the fractional reserves and then the
banks are obviously hedging as you
pointed out possibly not in our best
interest so in terms of that deposit
creation in December that's the largest
in history who where do you think that
money is coming from and in the casino
analogy who is that person i you know i
think i think deposit correction in a
sense comes from the fact that you look
at retail investors and how much they've
been investing in the stock market it's
since since the flash crash in 2010 it's
essentially dropped significantly so I
think there is a sense that people want
to just put their money in a bank
account and keep it safe to an extent
and I think it's a fearfulness that
comes from investing in the market now
do I believe that a big bank like a
Citigroup or JP Morgan is is necessarily
using those funds incredibly recklessly
I don't think so but are they do they
have hedging groups that claim to be
hedging the bank's portfolio but are
actually prop trading yes I do and that
was that was the example of the London
whale so I would hope the system and the
stock market becomes a little bit more
transparent where investors don't feel
the need to put their money into savings
accounts but can actually invest because
now that's what's helped the market grow
for so long you've mentioned a number of
banks that have behaved rather badly but
what are the banks that have behaved
well and have actually they been more
profitable than the banks that have
behaved badly if not then the you've got
a reversal of incentives yeah I think I
think you look at you know look at the
Canadian banks just as an example they
did not have a similar unending leverage
they didn't get into the same complex
product and they weathered the financial
crisis just fine I would say in the u.s.
you look at banks like Wells Fargo you
know that didn't have a similar I would
say ratcheting up of risk that kept that
fiduciary minded responsibility you look
at some of the more boutique asset
management places whose interests
weren't all over the place and de Neve
all sorts of conflicts and I think they
they survived a little bit better so in
retrospect I think banks like Goldman
Sachs and Morgan Stanley and frankly JP
Morgan were lucky to survive the crisis
and I think it was a domino effect that
was occurring that that the government
ultimately stepped in and saved so I
think could have happened to anyone but
the people who weathered the crisis just
fine were the ones who retained this
fiduciary duty
they weren't betting against their
clients they weren't using client
information to make themselves more
money at the time they were less
profitable but five years later I would
argue they're a lot stronger and unless
shaky ground so to speak in the case of
Canada was because of any government
regulation it was you know banks weren't
allowed to take thirty to one leverage
they weren't allowed to proprietary
trade in the same sense so in a while we
as Americans want maximum profit and
maximum capitalization like I was saying
that the speed limit topic is relevant
and if you have smart curbs that don't
allow you to make you know 50 times the
amount of money but also don't allow you
to lose 50 times the amount of money I
think it's it's just smarter and safer
for the system more broadly thank you
I wanted to say I applaud your courage
that was a great day to post on Facebook
your announcement and get feedback from
friends and family you've talked about
the ethical and legal dimensions of your
decision-making process was there a this
is your token seminarians question was
there a moral or a religious dimension
to that I you know a theme that runs
throughout my book is I am I am Jewish
and I do I do think one's upbringing has
some effect on things I want to talk
about idea of you know a charity or a
philanthropy or a university being
charged hidden fees I do think there is
a an ethical element that weighs on you
which I think stems from one's religious
upbringing and so I I do I do think it
had some impact on me and I think it
goes to this fine line between ethics
and and legal which I think there are
too many people who are willing to make
decisions that are technically legal but
not necessarily moral and I think
religion and my mind does play a part in
that
thanks for the question why don't we
take one last question they will wrap it
up basically sort of like a summation a
in order to effect change you have to
almost use the KISS principle keep it
simple stupid wouldn't couldn't you boil
down what you're talking about to two
items on a macro basis repeal the repeal
of the glass-steagall and and the
derivatives bring it back to where it
was in the Clinton era because it seemed
to have worked for 70 plus years and
secondly on a micro basis wouldn't
restrictions such as what's happened
with Morgan Stanley where the traders
now get compensated in deferred
compensation over five years wouldn't
that create the disincentives to bet the
house for next year's bonus a great
question I think EEP it simple I
completely agree with I I mean the two
major regulatory things I'm advocating
for are essentially repeal are the two
things that happened in the early 2000s
that led to a lot of the problems which
is derivatives being reregulate 'add
you know the CFTC has been sitting on
for two-and-a-half years and frankly has
not made a lot of progress achieving and
the second is the Volcker Rule which in
a sense is a little bit like many of the
things that glass-steagall stood for I
mean there's certainly people who stand
for the full repeal of glass-steagall
think they're huge political fears about
doing that but I do think some form of
breaking up extremely large banks
disallowing reckless trading activity is
noteworthy I think I think the thing
about compensation and deferring over
five years is essential but does it fix
the problem completely I don't think so
because the truth is if you swing for
the fence in your one and your bonus you
know and things don't work out you can
still leave and go to a hedge fund or go
do something else
I do think the law actually has to
become a little bit stricter because I
think greed and swinging for the fences
is always going to be around and is
impossible to start so I think you
actually need to change the root cause
which is you know if someone
Gambel's with clients money or bets
against the client that person
potentially needs to go to jail or needs
to have some disincentive that's so
great that if they're a reckless person
they're going to be two or three things
they think about before they endanger
the whole house so I think laws have to
change in addition to compensation
changing but but not not irresponsible
laws but just ones that create curves
that don't allow reckless activity I
guess your next talk is to the law
school
and I'd love to do it well thank you
very much
tomorrow the arms control Association
holds